[Music]
okay you never disappoint when it comes
to fashion you are serving up the
fashion game - thank you so much thank
you at me I feel like you're also taking
note from your caricature a little bit
is that a course that ice a bit of a
corset situation which I can't lie when
I wrap this show I was like never ever
again until somebody tells me I have to
well another corset on my own thank you
Lud Gord thank you so much good in the
series so fine a modern-day version of
Emily Dickinson here you are starring as
Emily Dickinson herself she's known as
this rebellious young poet so you as the
young gal but for you were you uh in
line or were you a little bit of a wild
one Oh Alto um I think I was a wild
child good night when I could be I mean
I grew up working and I grew up and very
sort of I don't know adult situations
that required me to be mature so anytime
I wasn't in those situations I was
definitely you know causing a little
trouble well you have everyone is just
sung your praises from starring in this
series but also to serving as an
executive producer on this show this is
your first time to serve in that role
what like for you I ate true learning
curve and an experience but something I
really loved when I read this project
for the first time it was so special for
so many different reasons and I wanted
to be a part and show up not only as an
actor for this one I wanted to be a part
of it on a different level and being an
executive producer has been such an
honor just on this project specifically
because I really do believe it's so
special well some of your fellow Apple
TV plus leading ladies like Reese
Witherspoon Jennifer Aniston they not
only star but they also serve as
executive producers on their series the
morning show did you take note from them
and wanting to take on this additional
role for your series and seeing them do
the same with air well they are two
fabulous women whose careers I've
definitely admired over the years and
I'm so excited to see the morning show
and it's just been so amazing to be a
part of such an incredible group a lot
like with Apple from Jennifer Aniston to
Reese Witherspoon to Oprah I mean it's
so incredible I'm just so excited for
the world to see this show on Apple TV
plus it's pretty nice company right
there okay so you're always in killer
shape
thank you but your dad your dad is a
personal trainer and he's your personal
trainer yeah yes oh my gosh it was it
like because he's also your dad is he
really tough on you in the gym so yes
but you would you would think that like
maybe he wouldn't be but I don't know I
go I go to him with with goals and
aspirations and he knows how to get me
there so the doesn't always work but
yeah he definitely pushes me have you
ever recommended him to some of your
celebrity and Brian definitely have yeah
he he's working with a few of my friends
at the moment which is awesome he he's
incredible I mean he's another level
yeah and finally I had I would read
something recently perhaps you're gonna
be a Disney pluses hot guy series good
are you gonna be joining Marvel yeah so
not only are you just I'm clubs coming
out on November first one
thank you
[Music]